unser bild reporter hagen stegmüller ist
vor ort erkennt die einzelheiten hagen
was bedeutet das urteil ganz konkret und
nahmen das urteil bedeutet konkret dass
er mindestens 14 jahre in der
psychiatrie oder im gefängnis bleiben
muss sollte er frühzeitig genesen zum
beispiel nach sieben jahren müsst ihr
weitere sieben jahre ins gefängnis werks
und eine normale justizvollzugsanstalt
sollte ja nicht genesen und im erste
dass man keine gesundheit bescheinigen
müsst ihr auf unbestimmte zeit in einer
psychiatrie bleiben also nur theoretisch
ist zur rente ist und im moment wo keine
gefährlichkeit mehr von ihm ausgeht
kannst du uns ein paar einzelheiten zu
dem täter sagen woher kommt der was ist
er für eine art mensch isabelle meyer im
prozessrecht schweigsam am anfang gar
nichts gesagt auch heute hat das urteil
regungslos entgegen genommen
er kam erst hat acht geschwister ist in
italien aufgewachsen was er aber
verheimlichen wollte als er 2015 nach
deutschland kam gab er sich als führer
aus und bessere short mit seinem
asylverfahren zu haben
dann lieber einige zeit in brandenburg
fiel dort schon durch diebstahl und
körperverletzung auf weshalb weshalb er
hier in stuttgart am landgericht auch
als einschlägig vorbestraft galt dann
kam er 2017 nach stuttgart lernte dann
wilhelm erkennen arbeitet die in der
gastronomie und nach einer gewissen zeit
verabschiedete er sich wieder richtung
frankfurt um auch dort sich mit
gelegenheitsjobs über wasser zu halten
und dann märz 2009 10 begann wollte
dieser religiöse waren als er sich in
den kopf setzte wie helga habe ihm
geschadet und allein aus diesem grund
carter überhaupt noch einmal nach
stuttgart zurück setzte sie hier in die
stadt fahren kaufte das samurai-schwert
zu seinem früheren wohnort zusammen mit
wieder ml wohnte passt ihn ab und
veranstaltete dieses fürchterliche
gemetzel hagen stegmüller soweit mit den
einzelheiten zu diesem unfassbar
brisanten fall und wir wollen weitere
sprechen mit dr
borwin bandelow
über die psyche des täters herr doktor
bandelow hören sie mich ja ich sehe sie
wunderbar können sie uns kurz auskunft
darüber geben was das für ein mensch
sein muss der solch eine tat begeht
ja ich habe mich bei dem prozess nicht
dabei ich kann nur das wiedergeben was
gesagt wurde in den medien
und das war wohl so dass er einen
religiösen wahn hatte also das ist
unsere wand vorstellung dass dieser bild
in allem schulzeit und einbau meine
wahnvorstellungen die führt eben vor
gericht eben auch zu einer schuld
behinderung manchmal auch zu einer
schuldunfähigkeit
das kommt immer auf den einzelfall an
weil so eine wand voll stellen kann das
gehirn völlig als geisel nehmen das
heißt man ist völlig an der realität
vorbei und weiß gar nicht was man da tut
und kann eben auch menschen umbringen
und denkt dabei dass man das genau das
richtige gemacht und lässt sich durch
nichts beirren
war das in diesem fall nur eine frage
der zeit bis dieser bahn zustand dann
nach außen trat oder kann es auch so
eine art kurzschluss handlung sein
das kann man so nicht sagen das klingt
ja so etwa beim die tat lange
vorbereitet hat also eine
kurzschlusshandlung kann man das nicht
nennen
aber in solchen taten sind unberechenbar
es gibt menschen manche menschen die auf
solchen vorstellungen haben aber nie
straffällig werden also bei
schizophrenie oder bei anderen
sogenannten psychosen kann so etwas
vorkommen dass man wahnvorstellungen hat
aber die meisten dieser menschen begehen
keine straftaten aber in diesem fall war
es wohl so dass er sich das so fest in
den kopf gesetzt hatte und eben völlig
an der realität meinte dass dieser das
opfer dann geschah ist dass irgendeiner
form und dass er das deswegen umbringen
musste in diesem fall dieser tat wurde
auch der maßregelvollzug ausgesprochen
was kann man sich darunter vorstellen
im maßregelvollzug ist eigentlich eine
psychiatrische klinik die er war so
gesichert ist wie ein gefängnis weil es
da da gibt es menschen psychisch kann
die straftäter die müssen
manchen fällen haben sie gar keine
strafe abzusetzen weil sie schuldunfähig
sind aber in diesem fall haben wir eine
so genannte schuldminderung nach dem
paragraf 21 des strafgesetzbuches das
heißt dass er eben nicht die volle
strafe kriegt man normalerweise für mord
gibt sondern eine verminderte strafe
immer in 14 jahre und die muss ja wegen
seiner psychischen erkrankung eben
absitzen im maßregelvollzug das macht
eigentlich insofern ein unterschied dass
man im maßregelvollzug auch medikamente
geben kann
zum beispiel kann man einen waren oft
mit medikamenten behandeln und kann das
dann auch ganz weg machen und das ist
eben in diesem fall sehr wichtig dass
eben da auch eine behandlung stattfindet
aber ansonsten ist es genauso gesichert
wie ein gefängnis und daher schon
herrschen sonst gibt die gleichen
bedingungen wie in einem gefängnis